yeah welcome to this game against
Turkish star super hydrated GM here
let's see what what we get the modern
defense or percs kind of Defense this
one yeah maybe I can transpose into
Smith Mariah again
huh
it's not taking why this is really
interesting it's one of the better
versions of the Smith moral really one
point is Queen Queen to be three in
early queen bee three provoking on the
e6 smooth black really doesn't want to
play oh it's a bit irritated at all
hmm
hmm well this guy is taking even more
time than I usually do okay I had this
some not too long ago against them
german german i am here on icc the venom
/ what's the name here okay whoo-whee
five
okay maybe five isn't that great still
in light f6 looks looks a bit dubious to
me to allow this attack okay I need to
take this probably anyway yeah let's
just have just develop here
yeah i'm not sure like 'if I've is such
a great movie re5 might be a might be a
problem
so just bishop here does he have any
great discoveries with the night don't
think so I mean by Bishop on d3 is
unprotected
mmm 95 looks looks good mmm you need to
get get out of this Fork sure but I
think maybe this isn't so bad Bishop f8
I have Bishop t6 I think
yeah but this this is final maybe am I
don't know maybe I should retreat and go
92 to see forms that could be it could
be annoying for him his is not very well
developed still the bishop on c 8 + and
so on yeah where do you go now they're
probably back only for it gets kicked
and I don't know if see for us really c4
is the paid place for the for the for
the night now I understand but maybe
here attacking attacking d7 and
attacking f4 and that's still have 92 e
40 this shapes up to be a very nice
position
we should be five now he's got 95 hmm
this looks very shaky
there should be 595 Quincy for
I'm muncher if this was really the best
but okay cannot spend much more time
yeah it wasn't the best man yeah he
tricked he tricked himself out of this I
or I did or whatever the the worst is
definitely over for black I even need to
be cautious now now this big Bishop b5
in c falls he was really on the ropes
there I'm sure was a really bad position
again now this is I don't know probably
about equal
his King side is a bit weak but I don't
really have an attack you can always I
think you're pretty easily defended
hmm does he have room to eat or
something
yeah I go here defend this I'm not sure
ma'am maybe I can he can take and 95 I
didn't really see 95 which is a bit of a
bit of a nuisance but it's a pin it's
not so easy
yeah 90 for coming okay I don't mind
that too much I've got the default
check
check
check
check
mmm how to play this for a win yeah
check
check
check
ah god damn it yeah well sometimes you
should just play on time and not look
for position I mean I could easily win
this on time of course here 30 against
13 but I try to find move still yeah of
course 94 here night see for Nazi for
night takes a five and I know Eddie's
the draw I mean it's even winning it's
even winning okay it's 11 seconds on the
clock you just get to get moves in yeah
a bit of a shame but okay I let him I
let him sleep here the position here
after I don't know move 15 or so was was
quite quite terrible here this was this
was bad I mean okay terrible I don't
know but it's certainly am really really
good for wide here this was good night
b5 also threatened not Bishop b5
fattening night be 5 D 6 and so on yeah
in the game it was it was not not much
happening but ok he didn't he spent lots
of time and does this double porn I
wasn't really a big big deal
yeah yeah okay yeah he didn't have any
time so this is why i butchered up this
end game and it was it was relatively
and I would not be 75 yahoo might be 75
wasn't exactly a difficult i forgot that
he's got got this this defense yeah well
not not a great game but a good fight
care thanks for watching